las calles de jartum yacen vacías y
desoladas y los residentes permanecen
encerrados en sus casas mientras
prosigue la batalla entre el ejército y
los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido tras finalizar El breve
respiro que supuso el alto el fuego de
este fin de semana Los bombardeos y
mortíferos combates se iniciaron en las
afueras de la capital sudanesa la ciudad
de ondurmand fue objeto de ataques
importantes nada se salvó como la
fachada de esta casa dañada por los
bombardeos
Cómo puede vivir la gente en una ciudad
bombardeada
golpeada y con francotiradores en las
calles
no hay tiendas ni servicios ni mercados
el acuerdo de alto del fuego permitió a
los civiles de la capital comprar
alimentos y medicinas pero con las
reservas que se agotan los residentes
luchan por encontrar suministros
esenciales
los servicios de emergencia tampoco son
accesibles y según la Cruz Roja solo el
20% de los hospitales siguen funcionando
ya han pasado casi dos meses y la
situación humanitaria Es muy difícil
faltan suministros alimentos medicinas
incluso para los heridos y lesionados no
hay posibilidad de ayudarles el
conflicto estalló el 15 de abril
desplazando a casi 2 millones de
personas Al menos 450 mil han buscadores
refugio en países vecinos como Chad y
Egipto la ONU Calcula que los combates
han dejado a 25 millones de personas es
decir la mitad de la población de Sudán
en busca de ayuda humanitaria